- So have y'all met before?
Have you ever met Tim?
I didn't know if y'all met before.
- Just backstage.
- [Kelly] Just backstage?
- Yeah
But not before that.
Like, "Oh, okay. Right on. Right on."
So I wanna talk about your new book.
So your new book is
called The Wind at My Back
which is such a beautiful title.
And this picture, by the
way, what a great cover.
- And that-
- It says so much
- That moment too. That moment-
- Yeah.
- Like it was the first time
that I was performing Swan Lake
at the Metropolitan Opera House.
And Raven Wilkinson never had
the opportunity to perform
on that stage as a black woman.
- But you see that in
your face in this picture.
- And she came on stage
and brought me the flowers
and it's tradition in
ballet that it's only men
that bring the flowers and the ushers.
So we fought to have this
black woman come on stage.
You should have been on
that stage performing
and present those flowers to me.
- Yeah.
- And I just like crumbled
because it was a surprise.
And I like knelt down
and gave her the flowers
and she picked me up
and she was like, "Nope, take them back."
These are yours.
- Yeah.
I love that though.
It's just the, I don't know
the expression on your face in
this picture says everything.
- It was like tears and
love and joy and everything.
- Yeah. Admiration. It's
just like all there.
It's very beautiful.
- Thank you.
- I love that it's the cover.
- Can you tell us a little about the book?
Like why you felt it
was necessary to write?
- Yeah.
So, you know, I wouldn't
be where I am if it weren't
for the incredible women in my life.
Mentors in my life, and then Raven coming
into my life at such a critical time.
I was still a soloist at A.B.T
and really struggling to find my voice
and place as a black woman.
- Yeah.
- In the ballet world.
And seeing her, you know, she
literally walked in my path
and my footsteps or I walk in hers.
- Yeah.
- But, you know, 50 years prior
and just also to see
how much hasn't changed
in the valley world
from 50 years ago and what
Raven had experienced.
I just felt it was
important for, you know,
again to see this,
the power of intergenerational
relationships
and the importance of mentorship
and having those relationships
with your elders.
And so it's a story of
Raven's life and my life
and how they come together.
And I don't think I would
be a principal dancer.
I would be here without the
relationship that we built
and the friendship that, you know,
we had she passed a
couple of years ago now,
but she just made such
a big impact on my life
and showed, gave me a bigger purpose
of what it is I'm doing.
Like it wasn't just about
striving to be a principal dancer.
- Mm-hmm.
- But it was being an example
and representation on
the stage for so many
- And a hero.
And it's kinda sad now that you say that.
Like, I didn't really put that together
but you just mentioned the two of you
'cause you're like there's
still not a big presence.
- No.
- And that's a shame.
- It is, yeah.
And I mean, it's so important, you know
that beyond the stage that I have a voice
and that I use my platform to-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To kind of get out there and
and to share, you know,
the ballet world,
bring it to more people
and try and bring more diversity to it.
But through my own
foundation that I've started
a program called the Be Bold program
and it's free ballet classes
and the afterschool space
at Boys and Girls Clubs
in the Bronx is where we're starting.
- Yeah.
- So it's, it, yes.
Looking back
and giving opportunity
is so important for me.
- Yeah. Well it surely was.
Look at that picture.
- Yeah.
- Well, speaking of dance
have y'all ever done like
a father daughter dance?
Have y'all done that?
[Both] Yes.
- I love that.
- This is a strange,
comedically I've been looking
at the way the world is and
because of the staff of Santa Claus,
my family,
my niece Jess is a dancer
and I don't know much about it.
My wife was a dancer and I want-
- Yeah.
- I'm just not into it.
I mean, comedy, I mean,
most dancing comedians
get is burlesque, which
is a form of dance.
And then I got into
this thing about ballet
and I don't understand it,
but between all it makes
me emotional to think
that this art form is an expression
of beauty through the body.
And they do it no matter
whether there's money
or attraction to it at all.
It's such an honorable thing,
now I'm a huge fan of ballet that they-
- Yeah, so so disciplined.
- Yeah.
- Well the the comedy
part is the worst dictator
in the world, Stalin,
murdered millions of people.
This, but not the dancers.
- Not-
- Something-
- There was a line, he had a line.
- Something to do with the
communists, they love it.
But I, my heart went out
to the people that produced this stuff
and all of our bad times, but especially
fine orchestras and then
dancers, people that do that.
And you, I'm just amazed
at what you people do
and how you express it.
It's art and love and design and movement.
- Beautiful. See your
body going like that.
And that's so cool that y'all
get to do the Father daughter.
I thought that was really special.
- Well what, book did we tell that,
remember that book you read?
- Yeah, it was literally
called Misty Copeland.
I had a book that I read when I was like-
- Just saw it backstage and the
look on her face, she's like
- I was like, "Oh."
- Oh my gosh, it's so funny.
We didn't know that.
- Every morning like I
would, I was, I don't know
probably like seven or
eight years old and my mom
and I, we used to read books
like while she was making breakfast
and I had, it was just like,
you know, picture books
like a kid's picture book.
But I read it every morning like-
- Oh my god.
- Every morning.
So when I heard, I was like, "Who?"
- Right next to her?
Just take it in, take it in.
Ah, Misty's book is called
The Wind at My Back: Resilience
Grace and Other Gifts
for My Mentor Raven Wilkinson.
It's out now y'all gotta check it out.